hi i'm tom payne from fox's prodigal son
and i am here with buzzfeed today to
read some of your first
tweets
how do i tell tom payne he's made my
life better and that i would like to hug
him when covert is over
i think i replied to this one i said i
think you just did it was very sweet
tom payne in the walking dead equals
amazing tom payne and prodigal son
equals amazing tom payne equals amazing
that's very simple i like how it didn't
grow it just stuck to what it was
but also only amazing in two different
shows that i've been in
i think the waterloo road fans might be
a bit upset about that pretty sure
rock me sexy jesus was preemptively
written about tom paine
i'll say that rock me sexy jesus i mean
it was a very rocky it was a very
rock and roll look that i enjoyed having
actually re-watching portable sun and
forgot just how beautiful tom payne's
eyes are
yeah that's been a big part of my career
as my eyes i get them from my mother my
teacher's talking about jesus's life but
sadly she's mentioning religion
not tom payne's awesome interpretation
in the walking dead i was
at an airport right around the beginning
of my walking dead
thing so i had hair like down here and
at the check-in desk the woman behind
the
behind the check-in desk said jesus i
was like
yeah and then i realized that she was
talking about the biblical jesus and not
the walking dead jesus
pinterest suggestions to me do you like
other blue-eyed actors
do you like other english actors do you
like
other the walking dead actors me no
literally i only like tom payne so
she'll [ __ ] up pinterest
i don't really like that one i want to
start watching the walking dead just
because of tom payne's incredibly badass
character
and because he's a precious cinnamon
roll i don't know what that means
there's a lot of internet vernacular
that i just am not on top of i mean if
you're going to start watching the
walking dead just because of me it might
shock you a bit where it goes and how
gross it is i wouldn't watch it late at
night
um if you're just watching it for me
because might give you nightmares
can we all take a moment to admire tom
payne in his hair eyes
and accent jesus is hot love heart eyes
hashtag the walking dead
[Laughter]
i love that that's hashtag the walking
dead because the walking dead has
fans you know all around the world and
they're all in it for different reasons
and i love that that tweet is so
specific about me
but hashtag the walking dead so it gets
included in every conversation
about the walking dead across the
internet tom payne is almost old enough
to be a sugar daddy
specifically my sugar daddy hashtag the
walking dead
talking death again nice to be included
in the full
walking dead conversation i wonder if
anyone else gets referred to as a sugar
daddy and the walking dead
i'm actually i'm pretty sure i mean
norman must have at some point been
referred to
as someone's want to be a sugar daddy
prepare to sell my soul to tom payne
at the current moment i don't want my
responsibility
i don't i don't think i could deal with
that like malcolm in the show like he
has so much responsibility and so much
emotional weight of his own
to be in charge of someone else's soul
seems a bit too much but thanks
i would honestly let tom payne throw me
off a cliff and while i'm plummeting to
my death i would thank him
oh my god that's dark but you don't want
to die i guess maybe
what is that then that's that's that you
want me to be the last person that you
see
or touch but i hope at the bottom
there's a soft landing
tom payne is so fine tongue sweat
why the [ __ ] do all these networks cast
these super hot guys to play psychos and
killers
then y'all are like girls only like
[ __ ]
wow maybe you're right maybe it's a
whole trick i'm not playing a psycho and
a killer though
i'm just quite unhinged no one asked but
my ideal threesome is harry styles and
tommy
so that's a i get that hairy comparison
quite a lot and i guess we kind of look
like brothers
i have a connection to harry but i i
can't i'm not
i'm not about to give it away but i
might
meet him at some point in the future
anyone want to talk about tom payne
i don't want to eat that man's i don't
know if that means
cook it and like eat the meat
of it or like get inside i mean just let
me know when because
i need to be prepared i'd suck tom
payne's dick for one pennies and a paper
clip
but that's not that's not enough really
you should probably get paid a bit
better than that i don't want to be
disappointing when will tom payne
actually come to terms with the fact
that i would ride his face until i rub
out all his
features
i like them i like ones which are clever
and paint a picture
that's painted a picture in my head like
ones that you can feel
and you definitely feel that and i would
be uh i would feel that i would be front
row and center for that trip
and that pleases me thank you very much
specifically that was lots of fun
you can catch me as malcolm bright on
fox's prodigal son
every tuesday
you